نريد التركيز الآن على
الوضع الإنساني في غزة، حيث
تقول الأمم المتحدة إن آلاف الفلسطينيين فروا
جنوبًا باتجاه رفح في الأيام الأخيرة،
وتصف المدينة الصغيرة الواقعة على الحدود
مع مصر بأنها اقتباس من طنجرة الضغط لليأس
الآن روسيا رافا قدر استطاعتك.  انظر
من هذه الصور لقد أصبحت
مدينة خيام، حيث يعيش أكثر من مليون شخص،
حوالي نصف سكان غزة
محشورين في قطعة صغيرة من
الأرض يعيشون في خيام مؤقتة
باردة ورطبة ومن الصعب جدًا
العيش في قضية حرجة أخرى وفقًا لـ
الأمم المتحدة: مستويات كبيرة من
سوء التغذية الحاد بين الأطفال تقول
وزارة الصحة التي تديرها حماس في غزة إن
أكثر من 27,000 شخص
قتلوا منذ رد إسرائيل على
هجمات 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول،
وأعتقد أن هذا رمز
لمستوى العنف والوضع الذي
وصل إليه  لقد ذهب أه حيث أه
العاملون في المجال الإنساني ليس لديهم حماية،
المستشفيات تتعرض للقصف
الوضع الإنساني في قطاع غزة يتجاوز مرحلة
الكارثة والوقت اليائس حرفيًا
الآن لتبادل
المزيد حول الوضع الإنساني المتردي
في غزة، نريد إحضار يان إيجان
وهو السكرتير  عام
المجلس النرويجي للاجئين ووكيل سابق للأمم المتحدة
للشؤون الإنسانية
ينضم إلينا الآن من أوسلو بالنرويج، من
الجيد وجودك ويجب أن أقول إننا
جميعًا نفدت لدينا الصفات
لوصف هذا الوضع فعليًا،
لدينا صفقة على ما يبدو  الآن مطروح على الطاولة
للنظر فيه على الأقل، لكن يبدو أننا ما
زلنا بعيدين جدًا عن
وقف حقيقي لإطلاق النار. ما مدى حاجة غازين بشدة إلى
نوع من الهدنة في هذه
اللحظة؟ إنهم يريدون ذلك
على الفور، أعني أنه لم يعد هناك وقت.
بالنسبة للسكان المدنيين في
غزة، لم يحدث في أي مكان آخر في التاريخ الحديث أن تم
حشر هذا العدد الكبير من الناس
معًا في مثل هذه المساحة الصغيرة تحت مثل هذا
القصف لعدة أيام، لقد مرت
أربعة أشهر الآن، وهؤلاء النساء
والأطفال محشورون معًا في
رفح في  في الجنوب، هناك أكثر من
مليون شخص فروا إلى هناك، لم يكن هناك
سوى 300 ألف شخص هناك في البداية،
هؤلاء الناس يخشون أن ما
سيحدث لهم هو ما حدث في
الشمال حيث تعلم أن المنازل في حالة خراب، و
350 ألف وحدة سكنية مدمرة أو
سيئة  متضرر، لذا، نعم، فحتى إعادة البناء في
هذه المرحلة ستكون بمثابة
إنجاز كبير، ناهيك عن مجرد محاولة الحصول على ما
تحتاجه للعيش على الماء والطعام كل
يوم إذا حصلنا على نوع من التوقف المؤقت أو
الهدنة حتى لو كان شيئًا لا يرقى إلى مستوى  وقف
كامل لإطلاق النار، ما هو المطلوب
على الأرض، كيف يمكنك التوسع في
هذه الساعة إذا كان بإمكانك الوصول إلى هناك لتلبية
الاحتياجات الماسة بشكل جيد، فإن أي أمر سيكون جيدًا أه ولكن
وقف إطلاق النار الدائم فقط هو ما يساعدنا حقًا على
المساعدة  غازا لدينا آه لدينا مثل هذا العدد من
الأعمال المتراكمة الآن من ثمانية والتي لم
تصل إلى غازا لقد تحققت للتو من
الأرقام اليوم أعني أن الولايات المتحدة
وألمانيا آه المملكة المتحدة والاتحاد الأوروبي
قالوا إنهم لن يكونوا قادرين على  إصلاح
وصول المساعدات الإنسانية إلى غزة منذ أشهر لا يزال
100150 شاحنة في أحسن الأحوال
اليوم أه نحن بحاجة إلى أكثر من 500
التراكم يشبه 50000 شاحنة محملة
بالمساعدات والحركة داخل أه
غزة شبه
مستحيلة على السكان المدنيين
وكذلك على  نحن كعاملين في المجال الإنساني،
لذا فإن وقف إطلاق النار الذي ينهي هذا
العنف الذي لا معنى له هو وحده الذي يمكن أن يمكّننا حقًا من
إنقاذ الأرواح عبر هذا الشريط الصغير
من
الأرض، ومن المفهوم أن الضمادة لن
تنجح في هذا الوقت خاصة
أنه مضى وقت طويل أريده  لأسألك،
قال أحد كبار الجنرالات الإسرائيليين لشبكة CNN إنه
لا توجد خطة معمول بها حتى الآن بشأن كيفية
تقليل الوفيات بين المدنيين في رفح إذا
اختارت إسرائيل التوسع مرة أخرى في تلك
البلدة الحدودية، ماذا سيحدث في
اعتقادك إذا قررت إسرائيل ملاحقة
مقاتلي حماس؟  في تلك
البلدة الحدودية، إذا فعلوا برفح ما
فعلوه بكيون ومدينة غزة وأماكن
أخرى، فسيكون ذلك بمثابة حمام دم
بين الأطفال والنساء من بين
الأبرياء، لذلك لا
أستطيع أن أرى أن الولايات المتحدة هي
التي توفر الأسلحة لهذا الشخص.
الدول الأوروبية الأخرى التي توفر
الأسلحة
لهذا القصف أه على
السكان المدنيين حيث نعم حقًا، لقد
اندمج هؤلاء المسلحون المتهورون في
السكان المدنيين ولكن هذا لا
يبرر بأي حال من الأحوال الهجمات العشوائية
على النساء والأطفال، وهذا لا يمكن
السماح بحدوثه  سيكون حمام دم
وسيكون وصمة عار على ضمير
إسرائيل ليس فقط بل على حلفاء إسرائيل